the world's largest container ship at
Britain's largest container Port the
everlot arrived on Thursday and normally
would be long gone by now but strike
action by Felix Doe's 1900 Dock Workers
has stopped operations
the unite union says a recently
increased offer of a seven percent pay
rise doesn't keep Pace with spiraling
inflation it's seeking a double-digit
raise that it says would share surging
corporate profits 71 million dollars at
last count more equitably with the
workers now unfortunately we've yet to
be given an offer which we think we can
take back and which reflects our members
aspirations and talking to our members
today and you know which we're in a
position to do as you can see
um we've we've had that message sent
back to us loud and clear
Felix doe Port says it was reminded in
recent Days by the bank of England of
the inflationary effects of big pay
Rises the port company accuses the union
of using the workers in a national
struggle on average for our workers this
is an extra three and a half thousand
pounds in cash to them each year the
action that they're taking now that
unites making them taken and you're not
having to put this offer to our workers
but the action that United is making
them take is actually going to take the
best part of a thousand pounds out of
their pocket the question is how far the
effects of this shutdown will Ripple
through the UK economy the port says the
effects will be manageable pointing to
the lessons learned during the supply
chain disruption of the pandemic
certainly the ever a lot isn't going
anywhere anytime soon and some industry
analysis suggests other container
shippers are already offloading their
Cargo in Europe instead of the UK the
union accepts there will be major
disruption and says that it could carry
out further strikes as it seeks what it
says is a fair deal up the road in
Ipswich Adam Scott's Printing and
embroidery business relies on imported
materials textiles ink and vinyl he
supports the right to strike but is
worried about further shocks to a supply
chain that's already stretched and only
getting costlier historically where we'd
have maybe two price Rises a year of
sort of two three percent something like
that we're now looking at you know eight
to ten percent price Rises monthly from
our suppliers so it's a challenging
environment for us over the last sort of
year
this Sunday's cargo at felixstowe was
restricted to day Trippers all sides are
settling in for a long wait for this
dispute to be resolved and it's just one
among many a long summer of industrial
action and economic uncertainty isn't
yet over Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
felixstowe
let's bring in just cholera he is a
senior supply chain manager at the
engineering and management consultancy
arcades he joins us now from Newcastle
thank you very much for your time what
is this going to mean then for delivery
times and for the supply chain
oh so
this is going to impact uh Supply chains
majorly I mean there they're going to
cause increase in two ways so one uh
increase in delivery time so delays uh
in terms of the shipment and uh increase
in cost because the longer uh the ships
are in the CE uh the longer it's going
to cost to keep them there so and it's
going to cause a further backlog some
Reports say uh just to clear the backlog
it would take 24 days which is way more
than uh what we what was uh what we
experienced last year you know when ever
given was stuck at sales Canal so it is
going to cause uh problems particularly
in two major industries so if we know uh
about what's being uh what's uh what
trades at Felix though it's
um it's uh mostly around automotive
industry and and computers so these
three Industries are already struggling
uh from from the recent semiconductor
chip shortage so that would add to the
costs so uh which is um already you know
interacted the cost of an economy which
is already struggling with inflation so
that that would be a major issue could
this lead to not just delays but I guess
to more demand
absolutely absolutely so this is
something you know in supply chain it's
called something called uh a bullwhip
effect so what happens is that when
situations like these arise it creates
uncertainty and then organizations
overreact so what really happens is that
they start uh
you know inserting more slack into
Supply chains right so by by buying more
so they would just try to build up stock
and inventories I mean the reports have
just come that you know in in the US uh
Walmart is struggling to write off
around 1.5 billion dollars of inventory
so they're just building inventory up to
just to just deal with these these
issues and also they try to develop
alternate suppliers in a very short term
in a very short amount of time which is
again costing money so that would cause
that what happens is that when there is
a lack of clarity in demand and Supply
then you know uh that is so again price
increases because you know you're paying
extra and extra and you're ordering more
than you need and again as that news
reaches to Consumers uh particularly you
know if this continues into the Autumn
which will affect the holiday season
then that triggers panic buying so empty
shells all that that just causes a big
big effect throughout the supply chain
sure one of the main complaints that we
heard there from the workers was that
you know the ports are making a lot of
com a lot of money that the shipping
shipping companies are making a lot of
money and that's not being passed on is
that true have the ports been doing
particularly well
yeah I mean particularly I mean from
from the last year uh and even before
that uh we know that the cost of
logistics the total cost of logistics
has risen because the world has broken
up to uh the fragility of Global Supply
chains so in order to make make sure
that the trade between between nations
functions are developed people
organizations are paying a premium uh
and also uh the seafarers because now
they don't want to enter into long-term
contracts they don't they don't know how
long for how long are they going to be
stuck at the sea they are charging more
and more so that is just overall causing
a rise in the uh in the in the industry
and also I mean this is the industry
which which is almost always operating
at a hundred percent capacity so it it
really has any spare capacity so that's
I mean they are making a lot of money uh
and you know there are reports that it's
it's you know that these are
organizations like profitable but that's
not passed on to the workers
particularly when you know they're
struggling with a double-digit rise in
inflation in recent times all right hey
thank you very much for your analysis
there for breaking it down for us that
was great jazz Colorado there senior
supply chain manager uh at arcadis
thank you very much